okay so when I talk to you in Dali on
Tuesday we had a great little film now
that I talked to you today you have a
golden globe-nominated film and she has
a nomination it's so exciting how
excited are you for her I'm so excited
she deserves it it's such a beautiful
beautiful song I was talking to your
producing partner Catherine earlier
today and we were talking about the fact
that it's a love letter it's just a love
letter to girls and it's so fantastic
and for you guys to want to take that
off and give this kind of as a gift to
girls to find their way in the space
that should mean a lot to you it really
does I mean that's what Chris and I my
partner in my production partner and
also she wrote it's all that it's what
we're really interested in is bringing
strong female driven stories you know
supporting women and about women now
that you know you and I are birthday
twins you've got a good one coming up
and are you gonna like what are you
gonna do you're gonna well clearly Ellen
starring me my birthday party so yeah
you
[Music]